hi welcome to architecting with google
cloud i'm gabe weiss
shared file storage is the unsung hero
of application development pick the
right solution chances are no one's
going to notice but pick the wrong
solution and you'll be chasing
bottlenecks for days no one knows this
better than our partners over at netapp
and today i've got oliver krause
technical marketing engineer from netapp
to tell us about a great solution for
windows file sharing oliver why don't
you take a second introduce yourself and
tell us a little bit about what you and
netapp do
hi gabe thanks for having me so i'm
oliver located in germany near munich
i over 20 years ago i started at a
storage startup called netapp
it became a unicorn and today it's one
of the biggest storage and data
management companies in the world
i held many different positions in that
company usually in pre-sales positions
helping customers solve their storage
problems
and few years ago i
switched to into our cloud business
simply to help do new stuff in the cloud
world glad to have you so oliver i've
got a windows application and i want to
run it in the cloud but i know there are
a ton of file storage solutions out
there maybe you could tell us just a
little bit about what's out there and
some pros and cons
yeah in the storage world we
have three different kinds of storages
the first one is a traditional disk like
a hard disk or an ssd or usb stick it's
basically a disk which you plug into
into your computer put the file system
on top of it and use it locally it's
also called block storage
after some time people thought oh it
would be cool if we could
use that file system on that disk on
multiple computers so share the data
and don't share it on a disk base but
share it on a per file base so basically
and file sharing was invented some file
sharing file systems were indented and
people were able to use data on multiple
vms or multiple computers in that time
and the new kit on the block is object
storage like google cloud storage
it uses http to store data
relatively new let's say 10 years or
something
and it's a great way to store
unstructured data
but most of the enterprise applications
in enterprise data centers
still don't talk object
but they talk
file nas and to share data
so people just say like just lift and
ship it's so easy but clearly if your
application doesn't speak object storage
that's not going to be so easy so you've
been around
what specific challenges have you seen
in terms of shifting a windows
application up to the cloud okay yeah so
let's assume we want to do a lift and
shift with a windows application
and that application requires data
sharing between multiple vms
which is by way a very common scenario
to enable that
you first need to deploy a gce instance
with windows the operating system
running
you need to size vm correctly
eventually you have to patch it keep up
the latest patches you have to monitor
it
maybe the performance requirements
change so you have to resize it
you have to think about backup and
recovery
and maybe even even make it high
available so multiple zones and so on
and after you did all of that you then
you can start to attach a data disk put
a file system on on top of it and share
it via the smb protocol to other
machines so hang on you mentioned smb
some folks might not necessarily know
what smb is could you just explain real
quick what that is and maybe you know
compared to what folks might be more
familiar with like nfs yeah so to share
out the local file system which is on a
disk
in a computer if you want to share it
out to different computers
you need a protocol to access the file
system over a network
in the old days
most systems have been unix
and nfs was invented net network file
system
which is still used in
unix-based or linux-based systems today
and very popular
in the windows world microsoft invented
smb which is a
abbreviation for server message block in
the beginning it was not a very good
protocol
but anyway
in the 2000s microsoft renamed it to
cifs sifs which stands for common
internet file system you know everything
had to be named internet something
later on um microsoft renamed it back to
smb
today we have smb version 2.1 and very
recently free which are very good and
capable protocols got it and i know
cloud volume services or cvs for short
supports both smb and
nfs so this leads nicely into what we
want to talk about today so to start why
don't you just tell us what is cvs cvs
is nas shares as a service
you create a volume
and share it via nfs or smb or both
to your clients
and since the service is super easy to
use and to consume and trouble free to
manage and how does cps help us
specifically with like a windows
migration for example yeah like i said
if you
do it
with a windows way you have to manage a
windows vm with all the edge
adjacent problems
cvs
in contrast is a service
so you can easily
create volumes you can scale them up and
scale them down both capacity and
performance wise
just you pay
per
gigabyte per month just like you do with
persistent disks and gcs
you get a build from google instead of
netapp because it's built through google
it's google takes you support calls so
it's supported by google
and additionally
we have snapshots built in and these
snapshots are different from the
persistent disk snapshots you might be
used to
so let me quickly elaborate on these
snapshots and give you free use cases
these snapshots are
instant to do within a second you
created a snapshot which is basically a
photo of your file system
you can do multiple of them
and with that you can build a history of
your file system like a versioning
system
and the first use case let's assume you
want to upgrade an application and
you're concerned that this upgrade might
fail and it changes your data and you're
left with an unfinished upgrade which
changed your data
you simply do a snapshot which is super
fast it's like creating a backup in in a
second
you do the upgrade if it works fine
delete the snapshot afterwards
if it fails
sim you have the snapshot and can easily
restore your data to the last known good
state the second use cage case which is
my likely the most relevant one for a
lot of customers
is
[Music]
you can enhance your backup and recovery
processes with snapshots
simply build a snapshot schedule which
takes a snapshot every day for the last
few weeks
and if you delete that file you can
simply go back
to that snapshot with a windows file
explorer so the user itself can do it in
the ui
they can simply go in there and identify
the last good version of the file and
restore it back to their file system
so it helps them
avoid a head death ticket and nobody
likes helped hit that ticket right
and the restore is much much faster
and you can even go beyond that
since snapshots are so lightweight and
cheap to do
simply take them every hour
take hourly snapshots and if you now
delete a file you not only get reversion
from yesterday from the nightly backup
you can get the version from last hour
which is way more current so that's a
super cool functionality
to reduce the recovery point objective
and the last use case
since we are talking windows operating
systems here
the issue with windows is
where
in danger that ransomware
infects them and encrypts all the files
on your disk
if you have since you have snapshots you
can take them every hour or so and you
have a very recent
known good state where your files not
have been infected
and the cool thing is you can really
quickly restore that files individually
or you can
roll back the whole volume
within
a few seconds half a minute or so
you can roll it back to the state of the
last known snapshot and basically delete
all the encrypted files by that
super cool and last thing
it doesn't matter how big your file
system is be it a terabyte or 100
terabyte
the time it takes to create a snapshot
or roll back a snapshot it's all the
same these snapshots sound really cool
can you can you like make copies of them
can you clone them into like other
for other applications yeah you can
simply
create a snapshot of a volume and then
create a new volume from that snapshot
and by the way this process also takes a
few seconds
let's say you were done in half a minute
or less yeah the so the developer in me
is imagining you know as you're talking
kind of popped into my head of uh you
know we oftentimes as application
developers run into a situation where
you've got a very specific configuration
of files on disk that reproduce a
problem for your applications and
sometimes reproducing that is kind of
hard but if you're making these
snapshots i can imagine a place where
you get a file you know a file system
set up where it reproduces the problem
you snapshot it so that you can make
changes and then reset to be able to
reproduce the problem that's super cool
so oliver i'd love to dive in a little
bit deeper here could you walk through
maybe where we can find it and then a
use case or two where we'd want to use
it yeah it's a good good thing is it's
directly built into the gcp console just
open the gcp console search for cloud
volumes
and it's where it's also on the left
side if you look up all the services you
will find it down at the bottom under
partner services
you will also find the documentation in
the cloud architecture center on
cloudgoogle.com regarding use cases i
want to present two the first use case
is a pretty generic architecture which
is used on thousands of legacy
applications
you have multiple gcv vms running
windows applications and they need a
file share to share data
so what you do is you simply provision a
cvs share and map it to the windows
systems
and we have multiple examples
where this applies the first one would
be for example vdi virtual desktop
infrastructure
where you have
smb shares for the user home directories
for group directories where people share
data between multiple users
and for the profile shares
another one would be automotive and
manufacturing
they're running a lot of computer-aided
design and computer-aided engineering
applications
most of them want to talk to a file
system to share data
so an smb share is the way to go here
and that applies to many other
industry verticals and the last one i
want to mention is media and
entertainment more and more we see that
these people have geographically
dispersed teams working together on a
project
and they all need to access the same
data when same media assets in a
performant and
consistent way to aid these requirements
we have a solution called global file
cache which builds on top of cloud
volume service
it helps you to share out
a share
globally to all the different sites for
example l.a london singapore
while retaining excess performance over
the wear network
on the other side minimizing traffic to
reduce costs
and enabling global file locking to
avoid conflicts when multiple users
tried to modify the same file at the
same time this is all really great thank
you so much oliver for being here today
and talking through this great
partnership between google cloud and
netapp using smb file share on windows
for windows application development it's
really been a pleasure having you here
yeah my pleasure thanks for having me
gabe
and if you all out there want to dive in
right away we've got links in the
description below to send more great
content to see this in action if you all
have any more ideas for customer stories
or architecture that you're interested
in learning more about let us know in
the comments and if you want to see more
of this kind of content click the like
and subscribe buttons see you next time
[Music]
you